joe biden is promising a return to
normalcy in u.s foreign policy following
the turbulent trump years
biden foreign policy agenda will place
america back at the head of the table
working with our allies and our partners
to mobilize global action on global
threats
but be careful what you wish for saddam
hussein
is still seeking the accumulation of
weapons of mass destruction
biden supported the wars in iraq and
syria and the drone bombing campaign in
pakistan
in the 1990s he co-sponsored a bill with
john mccain
pushing the u.s to bomb kosovo he
advocated a troop surge in afghanistan
before he later opposed it
trump broke with america's foreign
policy establishment
it all began with a dangerous idea that
we could
make western democracies out of
countries
that had no experience or interest in
becoming
a western democracy and though he talked
a big game
great nations do not fight endless wars
and has even installed a pentagon
advisor in the waning months of his
presidency to accelerate troop
withdrawal from afghanistan
thousands of troops will likely remain
there and in iraq
syria and elsewhere in the middle east
at the end of his term biden on the
other hand
embodies the establishment view that the
us must police the world because
building and maintaining the post-world
war ii international order
is what made america the indispensable
unquestionable leader of the free world
and in turn protecting us a biden
presidency might entail a return to the
obama-era policies of
aerial warfare heavy reliance on drone
strikes and maybe even a willingness to
enter multinational military conflicts
without seeking congressional approval
such as the libya intervention that
toppled moammar gadhafi and later led to
a bloody civil war
we came we saw he died
in washington dc there's a saying
personnel
is policy and new administrations often
draw from think tanks for both
trump's more establishment personnel
fought to constrain his
non-interventionist impulses
there were high-profile resignations and
one outgoing diplomat even admitted to
lying about
troop levels in northern syria after
trump had ordered a withdrawal
biden is reportedly eyeing susan rice
for secretary of state for defense
secretary biden is rumored to be
considering michelle flournoy an
obama administration alumna who
co-founded the center for a new american
security
an influential think tank whose experts
emphasized the need for more military
preparedness
against china and russia and a smaller
but ongoing u.s
presence in the middle east in terms of
abiding foreign policy
we know who joe biden is he's very much
historically
sort of ascribed to kind of liberal
interventionism and this notion that the
us
needs to take a big role in the
international stage
for the good of the world anil shilin is
a foreign policy analyst at the quincy
institute for responsible statecraft
formed in december of 2019 with seed
funding from the foundations of both
progressive billionaire george soros and
libertarian billionaire
charles koch it's a different kind of
foreign policy think tank that aims to
cultivate a roster of foreign policy
experts
who can guide future administrations
towards military restraint
it's named for the former american
president john quincy adams who once
said that america goes not abroad in
search of monsters to destroy
while it's a famous quote i think parts
of it has really been forgotten or
neglected it's not just because it would
be very
bad in the sense that we would be
overextended and would lead to
forever wars it's also because of how it
will change america
internally in which he says america can
become the dictators
of the world but in doing so she will
lose her own spirit and her own freedom
i think we have seen that as we have
gone abroad in more and more wars
the security state at home has also
become stronger and stronger
and many of the liberties that the
american people have traditionally faced
seen as absolutely
uncompromising have been compromised
trita parsi is the executive vice
president at the quincy institute
the vast majority of think tanks in dc
do not question the first principles
of american foreign policy quincy is
deliberately
different in that sense because we
believe that these endless wars that the
united states has ended up in
is a direct consequence of the us's
grand strategy of primacy or
global military domination the quincy
institute argues that the u.s
should abandon that strategy of global
military domination
and accept the reality of multi-polarity
or competing regional influences
the longer that the united states
continues to
to behave in ways that were more
possible when it truly was
the world's only superpower
are just going to continue to sort of
fritter away american resources
which really obviously need to be spent
here at home one of the institute's core
tenants
is that american foreign policy should
derive directly from u.s interests
rigorously defined
the united states needs to focus on
protecting
the territory of the united states
itself and the people that are here
one of the major bad assumptions driving
u.s foreign policy
is the notion that the u.s presence in
the middle east
makes the united states more safe and
this is fundamentally untrue
biden plans to keep troops in
afghanistan indefinitely
you do think there should be some u.s
presence that remains
yes a very small presence to be able to
determine whether or not i mean a small
footprint
what does that look looks like several
thousand people
she line says america doesn't need
troops on the ground in the middle east
at all
because a naval presence is sufficient
to safeguard america's main strategic
interests
which are keeping trade and travel
routes open and preventing the rise of a
regional hegemon that could threaten u.s
national security
there's really no actor in the middle
east currently that
would be able to take on that role she
says china has learned from u.s military
misadventures and seems unlikely to get
involved militarily in the middle east
while iran is too weak to become the
dominant force and russia operates
through a series of self-serving
temporary partnerships the u.s would do
well to
take a page out of russia's book and to
say look saudi arabia you're not
acting in a way that is supporting our
interests maybe we will go
talk to iran and we shouldn't be so
afraid to reach out to them
to stop iran's path to nuclear weapons
and missiles
i withdrew the united states from the
terrible iran
nuclear deal one aspect of biden's
foreign policy stance that the quincy
institute
agrees with is the president-elects
pledged to re-enter the iran deal that
trump walked away from
the iran deal was not only accomplished
in a critical mission
it also created an environment where
diplomacy was possible
but trump he walked away and i thought
the nuclear deal was actually very good
because it prevented a war with iran and
prevented the iranians from being able
to have a pathway
to a nuclear bomb once trump pulled out
iran began
enriching uranium at 10 times the rate
allowed under the deal according to
parsi
shiloh says that although saudi arabia
and israel have a stake in the u.s
continuing to treat iran as an enemy it
doesn't pose a significant threat to
america
iran's gdp is smaller than new jersey
this ongoing
animosity between the us and iran
doesn't really make a whole lot of sense
as u.s
troops leave the middle east parsi
suggests america encouraged countries to
form a regional security organization
but that it's crucial for the us not to
take a leading role in it
this is the instinct a lot of people
have in this town that we whatever we do
we have to be in the lead of it
it will take agency away from the
regional countries
and ultimately it's the regional
countries that will benefit from the
security architecture
their incentives to move in this
direction should be stronger than ours
while the quincy institute is unlikely
to be the go-to foreign policy think
tank of a biden administration with its
deep ties to the foreign policy
establishment parsi says more
politicians and bureaucrats will
eventually come around to their vision
for a more restrained foreign policy
quite possibly out of necessity and that
when it happens the quincy institute
will have the personnel at the ready to
make the pivot away from interventionism
a reality
i'll be frank i think what we are
calling for inevitably will happen
because we are bleeding ourselves to
death with these endless wars and at one
point it's just not going to be possible
for us to continue doing so
we want the shift to be a proactive
shift that is done before we have
weakened ourselves too much